I just find it mind-blowing Khloe  Kardashian sparks romance rumors with  NFL player Odell Beckham jr. buzz source  close to the 31 year old tells et  they're just pals speculation started  this weekend both Khloe and the New York  Giants player we're at Scott Disick's  Vegas birthday bash on Saturday and at  Drake's Memorial Day party on Monday but  our source says this isn't a  relationship quote they've hung out  twice they're definitely not dating the  rumors come less than a week after Khloe  filed for divorce from Lamar Odom for a  second time something else that's been  tainted well this might surprise you  Khloe's view of bellybuttons this is so  scary  the reality star just reveals her  biggest phobia on her app writing quote  I hate bellybuttons when I'm in the  shower I wear hand mitts and I scream  every time I wash my bellybutton  lol I'm just allergic to both okay